Tyler was this person who actually
reached out to me and he was part of a a
secret program now they're not they're
known not to be secret and he had
clearances and that sort of thing he
worked for every almost every space
shuttle launch okay he's a mission
controller and um he was a very
fascinating person um I kind of kept him
at a distance for about a year and a
half before I actually met him in person
I didn't believe in UFOs and he said you
only believe in them as kind of like
imaginary things he said what if I
showed you evidence that and so this was
where I was like automatically
suspicious I was like wow you know this
is crazy but I'll go um because you know
it's still evidence it's still data even
if he's it's diff disinformation it's
still data so um anyway so that's who
Tyler is Tyler is this fascinating Space
Program person